monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre monsieur le premier ministre la
situation de notre pays est grave
les crises sont profondes et elle
tranche avec les légèretés dont le
pouvoir fait preuve venons en au fait il
ya eu tout d'abord le rejet par me lapp
et nico les députés aient l'air om de la
proposition de loi pour toi 12 jours le
projet pour décès d'un enfant qu'elle
manque spontanée d'humanité il eu le
très sévère pour tout dire inédit avis
du conseil d'état sur des retraites qui
a pointé du doigt les risques juridiques
l'absence de visibilité d'ensemble de la
réforme et le flou sur le financement
que d'inquiétudes deux élus la vie du
même conseil d'état sur les circulaires
castaner relatives aux élections
municipales qui a pris la main du
gouvernement dans le pot de confiture à
deux reprises le conseil d'état avec
force vous a rappelé que nous étions en
état de droit il a pointé la légèreté de
vos copies mais ce n'est pas tout madame
la garde des sceaux a confondu liberté
de conscience et délit de blasphème et
le parc est allé jusqu'à ouvrir une
enquête contre la victime
on nous a pas entendu condamner avec
fermeté les propos du délégué général du
cfcm pour qui me l'avait bien cherché
les menaces de mort dont il fait l'objet
enfin le pont de la république a
lui-même contribué à ce sentiment de
flottement il s'est laissé tout sourire
immortalisée avec un t-shirt dénonçant
les policiers qu'ils ont senti humilié
par celui qui devait les protéger
enfin comment imaginer régler les
difficiles questions de l'assimilation
des jeunes générations issues de
l'immigration
en rapprochant guerre d'algérie et choix
monsieur le premier ministre vous
conduisez le gouvernement nous attendons
vos explications